so today we're sitting around 45 46 000
when that trillion dollars gets
allocated any thoughts in terms of what
happens to bitcoin
katie bar the doors pump i mean it
depends how fast they come in
i mean that's when you get extreme
extension of valuation you just don't
know
anytime people say i know the ceiling
and the price of bitcoin they have no
idea it could go anywhere and it's just
because
it depends and here's really what i'm
when i talk to institutions there's a
change in
philosophy about their thinking let's
just stay with bitcoin
bitcoin used to be considered for many
institutions that hadn't owned it yet
the ones that were just looking at it as
a currency
they're not thinking that way anymore
they're looking at it as a property
so you would buy it in the same way as a
triple a office tower in manhattan you
buy an allocation to coin that you're
allowed to own you never trade it you
own it as an asset you know it's
compliant it checks the box
you own it on your balance sheet your
providence
and
it's something that you can own as
property and that's where i think we're
going some percentage will still be
traded
but for the big institutions coming in
this is an asset class that is a
property i think i just heard kevin
o'leary say that bitcoin's price is
unlimited that's what i think i heard
but who knows
uh in terms of public companies putting
it on their balance sheet we know
microstrategy tesla square we also know
a number of the bitcoin or kind of
crypto focus companies in the public
market have done this as well is that
something where you expect over the next
year or two more and more publicly
traded companies will start to put this
on the balance sheet or are you thinking
more exclusively this stays in kind of
the investment organization uh corner of
the financial market for now
i'll tell you pragmatically what it's
going to take to get the s p 500 putting
an allocation to their treasury and
their balance sheets because
you know they are interested in in
starting to explore crypto
in exchange for cash reserves and we'll
go into that in a second on usdc okay
but let's just stay on bitcoin
that letter that larry think puts out
every quarter
that dictates uh blackrock's positioning
uh for sustainability we gotta solve for
that we gotta get larry on board for
bitcoin on a sustainability model and if
he's okay with it because that letter
actually sets policy
for
think about the way this works for
sovereign funds who he's the largest
asset manager in the world
and for domestic pension plans and for
universities and everybody else
you start he started this a few years
ago with the sustainability issue and
all of a sudden you saw the market
capitalization of hydrocarbons like oil
companies start to get crushed because
if you're an institution let's say
you've got you know five billion dollars
under management blackrock and larry's
telling you look we're not investing in
hydrocarbon distribution companies
anymore whatever his edict is
they're going to be selling
those and so what we need is is
you know i'm just i'm calling out for
the the guy that really sets the
standard it's larry fink in that letter
and his esg committee and the
consultants he uses
we've got to get them on board
and if he said look you want to own
bitcoin
this is how you can own it
and still fit the metrics around global
sustainability that's where we're at now
i've taken it upon myself because i'm
not ready yet i want to go there and see
his team and say look i'm going to bring
a bunch of representatives from the
mining community we've got to talk
i mean i want to be an investor in
mining i don't want to be outside in
compliance i don't want to be outside on
esg i can't i don't have that option i
can't go against
that mandate
so i'd rather get them on board what
what happens if you and i go see larry
fink at blackrock you've got your nice
suit on and your expensive watch and i
show up dressed like this do you think
that he takes the meeting
i think he takes the meeting i think
larry's a pretty pragmatic guy i work in
the institutional world you know that
pop that's where i am every day and so
you know
i'm sure that you know and i think
probably and i'm just speculating now
because i haven't done my due diligence
yet but i'm going to guess that inside
of his organization
there is a sustainability committee
that's setting up these mandates and
help publishing that quarterly letter
but you got to understand something pomp
that letter is
it is actually policy that's what that
is it's not officially policy but every
institution reads that letter the
institutional committees read that
letter on sustainability and they try
and abide by because lara's a pragmatic
guy that's where we're at in the mining
community right now we've gotta we gotta
solve this you wanna see bitcoin in a
million bucks a coin you gotta solve
this
is larry fink in your opinion the most
important person
in terms of getting institutional
capital to flow into the market if larry
fink kind of capitulated put together
this uh framework and said okay here's
how to do it do you think that that
would be the the inflection point
he is the most influential why because
numbers don't lie he's the number one
asset manager on earth
every geography works with him all
around the world and so look i'm just
calling it what it is he's the big dog
and he's put that sustainability man
that's out there and every industry you
should talk to the guys in oil and gas
they're not exactly happy
yeah it makes sense hey guys thanks so
much for watching that clip of the best
business show make sure you like and
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it